all right take a look at a couple of
examples in which having an extra extra
mounted material is not necessarily so
beneficial and we're gonna see a couple
of important defensive resources in
different end games that will allow us
to pretty easily draw positions that
somehow look hopeless so this was the
game between go glitzy and Kasparian
Kasparian obviously one of the famous
composers of chess but he was also a
strong Grandmaster in his own right he
was also a very strong player so this
was the game that they played for the
Soviet Chess Championship any many many
many years ago it's not 2015 a success
up there so what's the first thing that
you guys can come up with what so
obvious candidate move here for for
black it's black to move yeah anybody
right so let's continue a little bit but
should be three sharp Guinea seven
okay so now we have some issues right I
mean obviously blocking our window the
most I can hope for is a dry or you only
have a bishop but it's not so easy to
see how to do it because after Bishop
III checking me seven Bishop f7 there's
kind of some issue with h6 after h6
happens at some point I need to actually
use my king to stop the pawn which will
allow him to take my bishop and once the
bishop is out of the board the king is
shouldering the other and it's a very
easy win with the past epon correct so
it's interesting that even though
there's always this temptation in chess
and we're gonna see a lot of cases in
which a player four fell into temptation
that it's important to go back to your
basics always and remember your basics
now the reason that a lot of positions
are known in chests is because they
happen relatively frequently and they're
important to analyzing quickly can
anybody give me an example of a position
like a known position it can be on any
end game yes they lose seen a position
in the rook and game you don't need to
analyze it anymore if you get the King
in front of the pawn in a rockin game
then you know it's winning you just use
the Lucena method right we can talk
about the Philidor we can talk about
Vancouver which was what we looked at
last week correct
so rook and gives up a lot of known
ideas minor piece and gives not as many
but there are a couple of things and
rules of thumb that are useful when
evaluating and games of few pieces so in
this case which concept do you think you
have to fall back into yeah
so that's one one thing to look at right
the H pawn is essentially trash you
cannot clean the H pawn it's impossible
the only one that can be Queen is the e
pawn and when we realize this we realize
that offensive idea of the position we
never ever really care about the H phone
what we need to make sure is that the H
pawn cannot sacrifice itself in a way
that shoulders out my king or and my
bishop at the same time it just happens
that with the continuation Bishop e3
chuck kinney seven takes h6 I actually
put my pieces in such a way that the
pawn will sacrifice itself and my
bishops going to be lost so there's this
temptation of winning the bishop and
it's probably the thing you would play
in a blitz game before analyzing fully
but it's important to realize that this
actual a very bad idea
so what will be correct we should be for
Chuck and after King g7
maybe King H sermon is not such a bad
idea there's no reason that I seek to
give my opponent more chances than I
should so for example if I put my King
on h7 I now have to calculate different
ideas with King f6 and the bishop
retreating to f5 to gain a tempo it's
probable that most of those are still a
draw probable I'm not a hundred percent
sure but at the moment there's no threat
and it's important to realize that there
is no threat right you want to keep the
bishop in some way that I can just
control the diagonal so for example if I
play Bishop a5 and he goes east six I
just take it right it doesn't matter how
he takes back my King already controls
h8 which makes this a draw now the
question is what happens if Bishop e6
there should be four now you want to
always put the bishop in a position
that's gonna allow you to easily access
squares before looks okay in this
position I don't see anything wrong with
it and the idea is of course that if the
bishop goes to this diagonal you go to
the other and if you go to this diagonal
you simply retreat back to a5 so this is
kind of a known idea from the issue that
the pawn is on the wrong square of
queening correct so not terribly
difficult but notice that there's always
this temptation of going wrong you know
you be winning the P surprisingly is
incorrect in this position it's just
stopping the pawn with your bishop that
is correct
all right we're going to look at the
next one all right so this is actually a
more famous example this is the game
between Bobby Fischer some American dude
and Mark taimanov and they're very
famous match right that match ended
better no no how did the match end
how did the match and how it was the
final result Oh
6-nothing correct this was the second
match in a row that Fischer won six
nothing after beating Ben Larson six
year and then of course he paid he
didn't go 6-0 in the next match but he
won quite convincingly against Petrosian
so this game is quest actually quite
interesting because it seems like it's
pretty simple but at the same time it's
not and we're talking about mark time
out of here it's not like some random
guy is a very strong player but he was
unable to cope with the intricacies of
the position so what's going on somebody
give me some hints about what's going on
in this position wide only has one
winning try which is the Queen the pawn
right now if White had any piece that
was not a knight this would be an easy
draw I mean you just draw but the knight
is securely bad against h-bombs
correct so in this position we have the
problem that even though White has the
wrong colored pawn and he and the black
was given an extra night somehow this
actually looks dangerous for for black
this doesn't seem like there's an
immediate draw so let's think a little
bit about some of our candidate moves in
this position what what should we be
looking at yeah well it's what black
takuna so I just played King f6 right
cuz we're gonna be defending this block
playing us white it's not so difficult
to use shoulder away the denied your
shoulder away the King and then you try
to push the pond this is quite simple
kingi for us actually was played in the
game so let's analyze this first Keeney
for was played and then bishops see it
now the problem is that I'm still trying
to get closer to the pawn now bishop
state is a nice move because it puts the
bishop far away from the action in this
case you don't want to run to any
problems for the night or the King
getting an extra tempo you simply put
the bishop as far away as possible
it controls as many squares as a dozen
g4 but it's no longer an under attack
this allows me to play of course the
move each for in the next move
it's far more useful here than it is on
d1 you want to cut off the night away
from the pawn right now the added
advantage of bishop see it in this
position is the knight of three doesn't
seem possible
now let's analyze is not have three
possible why not why yes yes
right you play King g5 and then the pawn
man game it's obviously a win since the
king is on the wrong it's completely cut
off yes
so Knight of three is currently
impossible what else can we try no not a
threesome possible right so let's try to
get our king maybe a little closer
yes no maybe yeah Tina for was with the
amount of play and the Fisher of course
pushed his pawn forward because why not
so the only plan I have right so the
amount of trying out of three because I
mean what else can I bring my king any
closer
No so Knight of three because we're
asked and I put my knight it's not so
clear right in this position can you
play 94
let me throwing the questioners I mean
you can answer yourself it's 94 check I
move now of course what cannot take on
g4 right that part is clear however what
can didn't move so I have here as white
right in g7 aki-nee six because he
simply goes back I don't see anything
wrong with going back to you fine
the King g7 presents a problem right I'm
not trying to take but I am trying to
play h5 and then take and even if you
didn't have a threat it's not so easy
for you to bring your king closer so you
need to bring your night unfortunately
for you after h5 for example this thing
is not like it's not going so well here
h6 right yeah this looks pretty bad once
my pawn gets to h7 I'll be able to zoogs
wrong you for example Knight f7 of
course I don't take the knight I simply
go h7 and I think you're going to run
out almost pretty quickly if you for
example Don a g6 the same thing h7 and
you your king cannot keep protecting the
night forever actually it only lasts a
couple of moves your king age five
Bishop d7 King g17 g5 Bishop e6 with an
immediate zoogs on either you really
didn't question that defense of hid or
your play King h5 for ransom - Bishop f7
so this was no good night g4 was a try
but it didn't work so time I know
decided to try for Knight f3
however he ran into the kind of the same
idea of zugzwang with after night of 3
h5 so again I have to sum do something
right I can't play king e4 because he
just takes my knight King III and King
g3 don't seem to help me too much
putting my knight on e5 doesn't seem to
do anything
notice how strong the bishop on c8 is
right kind of a silly piece in the
middle of nowhere but it controls so
many important squares I Bishop on see
it's definitely a monster so 95 was
played and now it's where the bishop
really shows its dominance over the
Knight Bishop f5 was played and now
finding a move for black is torture you
know you can't play Knight of 7 because
the opponent game is lost
you cannot play night h3 you cannot play
night EFT you can't you have to play an
out of three you can't put that you
can't play anything that's not out of
three actually but that just retreats
the night to where it was
so after age six ninety five the only
thing here white has to do is pass and
surely it's winning so what's the best
move to pass Bishop g6 is probably also
winning I don't see anything wrong with
that move
it probably prolongs the torture for a
little bit because the King g4 is now
available to my opponent so it probably
wins somehow but there's a more
immediate win I don't want to let him do
anything yeah of course Kenny G six King
e5 is the only new alternative my
opponent has but because King e5 simply
runs into King takes g5k mg6 was
essentially a nice way to pass and in
this position there is just no way that
the knight can keep control over h7 if I
go to h7 and sacrificed my night while
the pawn and game is obviously lost so
after nine of three h7 char King f6 time
and of simply resigned not a good omen
for the games to come I believe this was
the second game so this put Fischer up
to zero in what should actually have
been one and a half half because we're
going to go back to this position at the
beginning and we're gonna try to be a
little more clever here time on earth
was trying to catch the pawn but he
forgot that he doesn't need to catch the
pawn and have all these pieces survive
see normally when you catch a phone well
you also have to make sure you don't
lose the night right but in this
position actually because the pawn is
the wrong color you don't actually care
if your Knights revive us or not the
only thing that's important is what what
is the only goal of the position yes
King to a checking thi draw right the
king control say traded to draw by the
law of whatever the King goes to g7 is
to draw because of one cemre in G side
when I can obviously go to H it so the
only trick of the position is figure out
how to get the King to g7 as long as it
gets there I'm safe so it started to be
a little more clever
in this X could be a start after King d6
what can i play that's nuts analyze just
for fun it seems like a decent enough
move Bishop c8 is not bad but what is
the problem what you remember that
bishops here was controlling a lot of
squares because the King was on e4 but
when the King was on e4 bishop see a
controlled f3 indirectly because there
was a check here I probably want to keep
control over f3 right I think so because
the King went on the other side I'm
still wanting to shoulder it but notice
that the bishop doesn't want to go to
see it anymore so where can I go control
as many squares as you can
deewan is okay my instinct would be that
eetu is a better move I don't know if 93
is possible by Y calculator when I can
just prevent it right it's the but this
idea of restriction this idea of
domination that we're talking about
where the Bishop is just restricting the
knight everywhere so for example here I
can go Bishop b2 another Knights kind of
stuck what can he play doesn't seem like
the king anywhere will help me so I'm
assuming 97th Chuck perhaps and then I'm
gonna go to g7 I don't see any problems
with that
maybe g6 to keep let's put it on g7 for
now
looks logical enough and yeah this is
already a better try definitely then
whatever time on earth it it already
looks a little mess here but still I
don't see any media draw it's possible
that the same game somehow a draw and
it's possible that here even in the Move
King g7 it's not best now it has to be
the best
I was thinking King g6 maybe 240 or
Knight to e5 might be important so what
I was trying to do was this hoping you
would play Chuck and then King g7 and
then the knight is badly placed on e5
right because I can easily advanced I'm
wondering if King g6 is correct I'm not
entirely 100% sure but although King
this X was an interesting attempt there
was a more direct idea here and we kind
of remember that we don't care about our
night and you guys are carrying too much
let's go with a further hint ideally how
do I lose the night that's I have to
lose it because I said so right and I'm
always right so I want to lose the night
where do I lose it by taking upon this
ideal but that's not gonna happen
if you take the bishop at any point it's
very a very dangerous pawn endgame right
there is something that you guys are
missing what is what makes this position
dangerous for black why is this position
dangerous for black let's start with
that question because your King is
stopping my king
get that guy out of the way
Knight of seven doesn't get them King
out of the way because it still controls
the important squares right I go to take
and King e5 and I still even though the
idea is somewhere the King still very
much where he wants to go is still
shouldering me out of the way
man and I thought this was gonna be a
basic lecture it's going on guys
why only five
if I I mean for my ignite to be lost
only five it means that I already got my
King to e7 and that's already quite good
I don't see how I managed to do that to
begin with my Kings not cut off on the
ear and gets cut off on the D rank which
is already quite bad
all right age for
I have to advance my pawn right there's
no reason for me not to
mm-hmm
haha and if I attack the night with the
king
well King at 5:00 sorry I'm gonna play
King at 5:00 right to keep your shoulder
it out right instead of playing King g5
yes
hmm
joy
okay it's an interesting idea right 93
h4 king of the night f4 and then of
course White has to play King f5 at some
point I have to dislodge your night from
f4 or right or I cannot progress and now
you're all going back to your instincts
you're just playing instincts from the
very first times you had just lessons
protect your pieces see if there are any
threats
see if it's hanging
keV I was what I said yes
Knight to e6 threatening with the idea
that if I go h5 everybody follows right
now g7 Chuck is a should be a draw right
because that's a double attack we're
looking at the line 93 h4 Knight f4 King
f5 and now the move Knight ecigs right
all right that's so far the most
convincing lines you guys have given me
however I would be slightly worried
about the move Bishop Bishop f3 thing ID
for okay
96 looks pretty convincing all right
instead of king f5 I'm gonna play King
g5 yeah that looks maybe like a better
alternate
yes
that's the easiest solution so you guys
are like making me work so hard actually
calculating variations and seeing how
does it on you that's by far the easiest
solution that I might have missed the
idea is to go back to what we said it's
the wrong color rook pawn which means
you don't need your knight
ideally you lose the knight in a way
that allows my King to penetrate into a
trade that's all you need to do you
don't need to keep your knight you don't
need to do anything else
so 93 would have drawn the game the idea
is that after h4 here any way you attack
the knight it does not matter king d6
and now you have to take the knight if
you don't take the knight then you can
never play h5 ever the knight the bishop
cannot attack my knight so you have to
take it and I go for King here you have
7 here and King J I get to my safe
square dead draw not so easy right yeah
I might have missed it so I mean if you
can feel okay for missing it as well not
I might have missed it against Fischer
in a very very important game of course
but it shows that there even though it's
a simple kind of looking endgame there's
a lot of resources and this was actually
a draw this was this was a draw after 93
all the other moves
I think they lose actually but 93 I'm
not so sure I'm not I don't remember if
after 93 h4 this was the only draw I
don't remember if 96 was also a drawer
no but Bishop f3 checking D says King f6
looks very dangerous right if I go here
check here here still looks dangerous
there's still a lot of zooms wrong ideas
maybe it's okay it might be okay but
this is an instant draw instead draw
nothing to do you have to take the
knight I go to e7 let's sign the score
sheets it's over all right let's go to
the next one so this was actually a nice
resource found by mr. Gary Kasparov
he's gonna be coming in tomorrow to st.
Louis to play in his magic in short and
we are in the game between Karpov and
Kasparov in their second car Kafka's our
world championship match this was the
one in 1985 this is game 20 yes 20 and
Kasparov has kind of an awkward position
it's difficult to make any kind of moves
with with black without allowing white
some kind of make a progress right for
example if I put my king on e6 then
while the trade of bishops looks lethal
to me if I put my king on e7 or c7 then
white can go king c5 45 depending on
what I chose further attacks and if I
move my Bishop it looks like well Bishop
ba takes all of my pawns right so
Kasparov simply remembered that in this
kind of any games what matters the most
is eliminating all of my opponents
dangerous pawns and how many dangerous
Ponce is my opponent half to the H pawn
is worth nothing as long as I can
sacrifice my bishop for the H bone it's
an easy draw for the F pawn it San
Ysidro as long as I first get which
point the a points of the only thing
that matters therefore the correct move
in this position is Bishop b3 now if
King c3 I simply go Bishop f7 and
there's no way to make progress I mean
at some point you have to put the King
on d4 so Karpov tried Bishop e8 and now
the important thing is to force White's
hand if there was another row and I
could play something like Bishop d9
attacking g6 this wouldn't be a draw
because at some point you know the King
cannot get in this tempo but this is how
it works King e7 gaining the tempo takes
this forced takes takes King f6 and the
players didn't even bother playing it
out now if this was shuffled one row
back this would be very different
because then I have the right color
bishop right that would be completely
different scenario but because it's a
light square bishop the only thing that
I have to do is make sure that my bishop
at some point sacrifices itself for the
correct pawn and it's dead wrong now end
games are always kind of tricky and
we're good and we're not going to go
through this entire example in what is
famous for being the longest game ever
played in a world championship match
this is the game between Viktor Korchnoi
and Anatoly Karpov from their 1978
encounter who on that of course question
was narrow world champion what's wrong
with you guys victor ii very good some
chess culture right there now the
question is this it is a draw aha
suddenly things are not so easy
first of all is my king shouldered out
as black
it's black to move
not so easy right you have to calculate
quite a bit the defense here is actually
quite difficult but Karpov managed it
very well you still have to keep the
king close enough to the square c8 so
that I can go back to a8 at some point
as soon as the king takes on b5 right so
what ended up happening was this and
this was a long game guys long now
Karpov is very cleverly that's avoiding
something if for some reason he gets
stalemated by the bishop he loses
because the b-pawn has to sacrifice
itself and it becomes the a pawn from
white becomes a be pawn and my bishop
will stop the a pawn
right I'm that means like in any
scenario of course specifically here had
the stalemate occured the pawn simply
promotes but I'm saying it doesn't
matter where the King would have been as
long as there's a stalemate you lose and
well Karpov was patient enough never to
fall for any of these traps of course
the Bishop can always try to shoulder
out the King but it's impossible even
though the Kings know all the way on g2
it's still actually making it and a
cautionary for as much as he tried and
this was as close as he got it's still
well within reach of the king and after
king c6 the draw is actually slightly
easier but it's not a big deal
victor ii kept trying but eventually he
had no choice but to stalemate his
opponent now the draw was easier because
if you see Karpov could go to the corner
on h8 whereas before he couldn't go to
the corner on any trader
exactly if he goes to the corner you for
stale made before loses a lot of
interesting little details for this
position all right so we're looking at
the game Hikaru Nakamura versus being
black against Luqman Valley
Shekhar Nakamura st. Louis resident
obviously playing against one of the top
Dutch Grand Master's and now we have a
very interesting position because well
obviously what White's up a pawn and
after rook takes e4 he's up two points
good for him
so which concept do you think is going
to help us draw this game
wrong color rook pawn with the right
with the wrong bishop right wrong okay
this one is not this one is useful
because it's always so good to know
things in the endgame it's not about
thinking it's not about evaluating it's
about knowing you know and one of the
things that grandmasters do is know they
just know you ask them well why is this
position better it just is you know I
know it I know I don't have to ask
people I don't have to think it is in
this position he Cara knows that this is
a drop however his method was a little
unique he played the move Bishop d1 rook
f4 and this looks hopeless a bishop
takes up three rook takes f3 the rook
and game is completely lost the King is
way too far away from the airport
so the correct move is rook every Rock
every Bishop a4
this specific endgame with the pawn
queening on h8 me having a LightSquared
bishop and the rook pawn having passed
the fourth-ranked it's a draw we will
analyze why this is a draw and why would
the pawn h4 it's a win but they're very
different scenarios
now both grandmasters knew this was a
draw when well they tried for no moves
at all this is already unknown draw and
Christ
quite honestly would have been a waste
of everybody's time had he tried so I
was simply drawn after this now the
interesting thing is that well you guys
would have never thought of this but
this does lead immediately to a draw so
let's analyze why this is the game
between Eugene max max Buda against some
guy I don't know how to pronounce that
and the world champion here with white
with black blundered horribly with the
move h4 turning the position into a unto
a draw
h4 in central now we're going to analyze
the method to win now the problem with
h4 is that once the Bishop gets to this
diagonal the H to be a diagonal there's
no way to extricate it from the diagonal
you can always stay in the diagonal all
right we're gonna see a couple of
examples that even if you move it out
temporarily it always goes back in and
the problem is how do you make progress
check on a wine king f2 right I can't
play King g3 which be completely lethal
is just illegal if I go King g4 I don't
help myself if I go to f3 and go check I
just go to h2 what the problem is pretty
interesting kind of end game now the
method from here is pretty simple after
roopd to Bishop e3 or whatever check
King F to rook d7 and you always make
sure that the bishop can't get back into
the diagonal H to b8
now if for example he played the move
Bishop b6 then I play rook d7 I keep the
bishop out of h2 b8 well and then you
might be questioning well well yeah that
was obviously very easy now this is
obviously winning because I'm gonna play
King g3 route d1 but what if the bishop
starts on the diagonal H to be a right
so here's the thing and this is the
winning method for this specific endgame
Bishop it's white to move so Bishop B
egg I attack the bishop whatever I
played my king to h3 I play here I
attack the Bishop Bishop b8 and now
Bishop zombie 8 or whatever I play like
this this is the winning idea rook g6
cutting the King on the G file notice
that I could have forced this you know
when I play check the King has to go to
the F file if it ever goes to the H file
I gain a temple on the bishop and
threaten checkmate at the same time yeah
or more precisely I put my work in a way
that doesn't allow the bishop to go back
to g1
so after 36 Bishop c7 here with the pawn
on h4 it's impossible to make progress
it just so happens that when the pawn is
not an h4 you simply retreat the king
it's might look a little
counterintuitive but the idea is this
King f3 root chief for Bishop e5 because
you need to keep that's diagonal right
King g5 the ship c7 and now I pushed
upon I've made sure the king is out of
the corner
I moved the King from h1 to f3 right and
now that the king is not in front of the
pawn I simply move my King out of the
way and now this is winning because I'm
going to go king f5 h3 rubgy to put the
rook on a 2 h2 nothing to do about it
right everybody follow that yes this is
already a pretty easy win whereas the
example here after h4 once I got my root
2 G 2 I ran out of squares
I cannot retreat my king this is the
problem the king was on h3 in both
examples because I needed to get my
route to the G file right to move the
King to f1 or to the F file but once the
King was on h3 got stuck what ended up
happening was that if I retreat my rook
on the G file here and I'm my opponent
does whatever and I go King G for the
king with regains g2 and regains h1 so
the only way is to put the rook on g4
bring the King behind the rook and win
that way this is the only way of winning
h4 ruins the ruins the win all right
time for a basic example Greco back in
like 1600 yes
in completely incorrect Bishop page
three I take the rook and then I laugh
or I can also okay always in the correct
order of operations right okay one oh
it's gonna set it to the wrong person to
play okay one here this was just
compositions back in the 1600s alright
next example awesome alright now this is
one of the most famous examples of
escaping into a draw this is the game
between large loss Java or Java or
whatever and a super-strong player of
course from hungry and he's playing
Mihiel Babinec world champion pretty
strong guy and this is about knowing
knowing rook takes g5 was played in this
position and then Botvinnik realized
that he cannot take on a five because
ninety seven checkpoints the exchange
but anything else also looks pretty
bleak
I mean f7 rook g8 is a threat h6 doesn't
seem to help me that much because also I
can play rock h5 route and I g6 is also
a possibility it's a million things
white can do this looks really bad but
Botvinnik
no rook takes a 597 shark takes takes
Bishop g4 and despite white spawn on f6
this position is a draw known as the Del
Rio position is the del Rio position is
known specifically after this position
once because the pollen h didn't matter
at all
this position is unknown draw
the bishop has so many squares to go to
to keep the King out of g6
that the positions are draw the drawing
technique is relatively simple you keep
the bishop in one of the positions
between a 2 B 3 C 4 or D 5 so as to
allow a check on the diagonal b1 to h7
when the King goes to g6 if the King is
not on g6 you keep playing Bishop a 2 B
3 C 4 D 5 depending where the rook
allows you to go now between the rook
and the King they cannot kick you out
they cannot control that many squares
interesting little detail of an endgame
but this is a non draw now a little
detail and it's important is that this
only works with an F pawn or a C pawn of
course because Mir if sorry
if it's a jeep on I'm not entirely sure
if it's an e or D pawn the bishop runs
out of squares because notice that my ax
diagonal became shorter now if there's a
jeep on there's also a problem but I
don't remember what it is I want to say
that you get checkmate at somehow but I
don't I don't quite remember how yeah of
course it's at the only this only works
with the bishop being on opposite
squares because you need to control the
squares around the pole right you don't
need to attack the point you to control
the squares around the point so Java
tried something relatively clever after
realizing that he was getting nowhere
and he played the Move f7 and now the
key to this endgame and it doesn't
matter which way you go is that here
Bishop takes f7 is lost you just play
King e7 and white can make no progress
the point is that F's if f8 takes King
f6 you don't gain a tempo against my
bishop
therefore I go King e8 and I draw pretty
easily if you go King g6 and defend your
pawn I don't take a look
I simply keep attacking your pawn the
rook is stuck defending the pawn the
King cannot move forward because the
defense of the pawn is doomed the bishop
very conveniently controls both g8 and
g6 where the King would pin an attack so
after King g7 this is still a draw if
route g7 I pass you're not running
anything f8 chuck was played takes here
king e7 draw agreed
one of the most miraculous escapes in
the history of chess is not actually
just because of a blunder it was because
of a brilliance of the player now to
counter that I don't know why I have
this here to counter that this was the
game between somebody and somebody which
I will not say their names for
embarrassment but here what do you think
black played
he took with the pawn which is having no
knowledge this is a win with the G pawn
especially because the pawn hasn't
crossed all the way down to the third
rank therefore it's pretty easy to win
you're just kind of shoulder out the the
Bishop you bring in the King
the winning technique is as follows now
that you asked I think this is pretty
much applicable even if the ponies on g3
check here work here you move out the
from the square and after King e5 you go
route B five here check your check here
in King each one and he the point is
that because it's a jeep on there is not
enough squares on the diagonal to always
be for you for you to always control it
you can't always control a position on
the h4 d a diagonal whereas with the
real position you can always control a
b-1 h7 yeah depends on where the pawn is
remember if it's an H pawn and it's on
h2 h7 it's a loss
h4 for white it's still a win for white
but it goes to h5 it's suddenly a drop
it's it's a win correct because of the
method of extra cating the bikini is
always winning three D G d e b always
winning always running doesn't matter
where the point is what Bishop color
will look nothing the rook can always
shoe away the bishop it can make it run
out of squares the the board is not big
enough for the bishop to keep checking
to hide so in this position after king
h4 there's no way to avoid a deadly
check on the second rank for example if
I go Bishop f4 simply rotate three with
the following rook a to Chuck and then I
get King h3 in I get g3 in and that's
obviously the end of the game right
so our unfortunate player played GT x f3
and fifty moves later had to agree to a
draw because this is the drawing game
all right I hope I have bestowed some
useful knowledge onto your minds
remember a lot of things about end games
and the reason that in games can be
analyzed so quickly by grandmasters it's
not that we analyze oh wow is this a
draw
no we know except this guy but we know
you know we know the del Rio position we
know that on Korea we know that luiseño
we know Philidor we know all these kind
of ideas and it allows us that well
we're in the game we know wait I can do
this where I can't do this because I
know it's a drawer to win this is how
nakamura drew van well ii in that almost
lost position this is how Botvinnik drew
jabo
in what was surely a lost position
without this resource so I hope you guys
enjoyed it that's pretty much it for
today